Film Courage: Do you get nervous when there
is nothing in the works [screenwriting wise]
or is there a sense of freedom because of
the possibilities of what could happen?
Do you almost thrive off of that?
Screenwriter Gary Goldstein: Good question.
I don’t know if I thrive?
Honestly because careers can be such roller
coasters and as a writer you can go through
many periods where you are really not working
for hire and hopefully you are writing on
your own and cranking out material and utilizing
the free time.
But because there can be a lot of downtime.
It can be nerve wracking.
Honestly, the ideal thing is to have enough
work along the way to keep you financially
solvent and have a little down time in between
to work on your own projects.
You know based upon what you like to do.
I mean I like writing stage plays, so I like
to have time here and there.
Recently I had shoulder surgery and I was
home (mostly I didn’t leave the house for
6 weeks) and I could only type with one hand
but I was able to use my other hand.
And I just said “You know what, I’m going
to finish something at the end of this 6 weeks.
It’s tough being here.
I’m in pain.
I’m going to finish writing something.”
And I had started a new play before I had
the surgery and I had literally just finished
this new play at the end of this period and
it was just so great.
And I’m very happy with that particular
play.
I’m looking forward to continuing to work
on it.
But I didn’t have an assignment at that
time so it did give me the freedom to write
it and during that period not feeling all
that great, it was really nice not to have
someone waiting for something from me because
I didn’t want to have to disappoint them
because of the pain or whatever.
So that was a good period to not be on assignment.
But by and large I like it to be, air on the
side of more work, more paperwork, more assignment
work than not.
It’s very, it’s like charging your batteries
are charged.
I like knowing there is stuff out there happening.
But I’m always just working on something
and writing something or trying to market
old scripts or work with my agent and get
new meetings and make things happen.
So I really utilized the time to do that.
What’s nice about having a little free time
is that you can get back to your career and
your bigger picture of your career.
Because when you’re nose-to-the-grindstone
sometimes you forget “Well, I did have that
script I was trying to sell.”
Or “I still did want to get that assignment
there” Or “I want to be on that show there”
or whatever and you just can’t do it because
you’re too focused on your work and the
issue at hand.
So it’s nice to have a combination of both.
But you’re probably better off having the
work (more work than not, I think).
Film Courage: Well, it goes back to what you
said about focusing too much on the minutia,
so it sounds like even though you do like
to be working and you like to have stuff going,
it sounds like to have a little bit of breathing
room, you can stand back and see more.
Gary Goldstein: Yeah, you can sometimes lose
the big picture when you’re in the cave.
And then when you get out of it then you can
say “Okay, out now.
I’ve got a little time.
Where am I?”
Because as you know, as a writer (and it’s
similar for directors and producers) you have
to be the master of your own ship, master
of your own destiny in terms of your career.
You have to keep it moving forward if you
want to keep working.
And an agent is great but they can do so much.
It’s really up to us to really stay on top
of it and focused in term of what our end-game
is or what our goals are.
What are my goals?
To keep writing movies that get made and write
things that are meaningful to me and that
I hope people will enjoy and all of that and
tell my stories and that kind of thing.
But that doesn’t just happen.
And sometimes you have to really just keep
your eye on the ball because time goes very
fast.
And if it’s not you, it will be somebody
else and we have a finite amount of time on
this planet.
Film Courage: Absolutely.
And going back to when you left one career
(and you don’t have to go into too many
details about it) but were you able to step
back from a lot of minutia at that point because
you probably had more free time of your hands?
Gary Goldstein: It was a really weird time
because I was so used to getting a steady
paycheck.
Fortunately I had stashed away enough money
to go through this process until I got work
again.
But that was the thing to kind of be okay
about just getting sporadic paychecks and
not knowing when the next paycheck was going
to be and then knowing that this was just
a safety net (basically) and that part was
difficult.
But when I left that job and started to become
a screenwriter (TV writer at that point),
it was all focus all the time for me.
I mean it was like I just dove into the deep
end.
And I mean there was so much to do and so
much to write.
It was…like starting a whole new career.
It was just a lot to learn and be out there
a lot and really just keep my eye on the ball.
So it was an exciting time but definitely
challenging.
It was not a lot of down time.
And also back then I would feel very guilty
about having down time.
I would feel like I shouldn’t be going to
the movies, I should be working on my new
spec script or something.
And I mean that was hard.
It took a long time for me to not feel guilty
for not working but that eventually happened
when I was like “Okay, I’ve got enough
work and I don’t want to be working at that
moment.”
That was okay.
But you got through phases, every career has
its phases.
And we grow as people as you experience more
and as you become more confident or just more
self-possessed or just less beholden to the
forces out there.
Film Courage: Well I think too, it probably
didn’t take training for you to get out
of that 9-to-5 or whatever it was 9-to-7 mindset?
Gary Goldstein: Well it kept me pretty structured.
I was so used to that kind of 9-to-5 (well
that job was 9-to-9).
But I was used to getting up early, used to
getting my work done, used to having a goal
for everyday.
So that translated really well when I was
on my own.
Because otherwise I would have been like “Oh,
my gosh.
How am I going to organize this?
What am I going to do?”
That part wasn’t an issue.
It was just like “Will I get a job?
Will I be successful?
Will I really be able to make a go of this?”